chers amis bonjour henri kubnick
aujourd'hui a rajeuni de 30 ans et oui
vous le savez à présent c'est en 1958
qu'elle est l'un de ses enfants sous un
chapiteau illuminé un soir de fête au
plan iliad vantant les fesses et la sous
préfecture de l'indre qui accueillait
pour la première fois un nouveau jeu
d'henry souvenir c'était 5000 francs par
jour qui allait devenir le jeu des mille
francs depuis ce jeu des mille francs la
doyenne des émissions vedettes d'essence
inter a fait le tour du monde et pour
fêter ce 30e anniversaire lucien
jeunesse
l'homme qui n'a jamais si bien porté son
nom à présenter cette émission en
présence de roland faure président de
radio france et jean garretto directeur
de france inter depuis 1958 le jeu à
consommer un peu plus de 70 mille
questions envoyées par des auditeurs ce
jeu qui se veut avant tout éducatif et
conviviale s'est promené à travers toute
la france
et jusque sur le porte avions clemenceau
le paquebot massalia et dans un sous
marin
cette émission a été relié en direct par
les réseaux dont deux courtes qui balaye
tous les continents et les
enregistrements envoyés dans toutes les
stations de la france d'outre-mer et les
républiques francophones d'afrique pour
l'animateur fétiche de france inter ce
jeu est un bijou vance
quand j'arrivais les choses bonjour que
je vois tous les gens éclaté de sourire
et et moi sourire gentiment c'est un
bain de jouvence hoyé cette
extraordinaire
c'est pourquoi je fais ce jeu depuis peu
de temps depuis 23 ans seulement et j'ai
l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas de
commencer mais de faire ce jeu depuis un
an ou deux on constate que ce jeu
continue à intéresser beaucoup le public
puisque c'est une tranche qui vient de
gagner plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'auditeurs donc l'ancien manceau ne
s'éteint pas intérêt mais ça c'est la
pauvre progresse et ça progresse parce
que les gens finalement s'instruisent en
se distrayant merci à ma main si vous
voulez bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]